How to slice and dice a dataset.
Most of the time, the data you work with won’t
be perfectly prepared for training models.
In this video we’ll explore various features
that Datasets provides to clean up your datasets.
The Datasets library provides several built-in
methods that allow you to wrangle your data.
In this video we'll see how you can shuffle
and split your data, select the rows you're
interested in, tweak the columns, and apply
processing functions with the map() method.
Let's start with shuffling. It is generally a
good idea to apply shuffling to the training set
so that your model doesn't learn
any artificial ordering in the data.
If you want to shuffle the whole dataset, you
can apply the appropriately named shuffle()
method to your dataset. You can see an example of
this method in action here, where we've downloaded
the training split of the SQUAD dataset
and shuffled all the rows randomly.Another
way to shuffle the data is to
create random train and test splits.
This can be useful if you have to create your own
test splits from raw data. To do this, you just
apply the train_test_split method and specify how
large the test split should be. In this example,
we've specified that the test set should be
10% of the total dataset size. You can see that
the output of train_test_split is a DatasetDict
object, whose keys correspond to the new splits.
Now that we know how to shuffle a dataset,
let's take a look at returning the rows
we're interested in. The most common way
to do this is with the select method.
This method expects a list or
generator of the dataset's indices,
and will then return a new Dataset
object containing just those rows.
If you want to create a random sample of rows,
you can do this by chaining the shuffle and select
methods together. In this example, we've created
a sample of 5 elements from the SQuAD dataset.
The last way to pick out specific rows in
a dataset is by applying the filter method.
This method checks whether each
rows fulfills some condition or not.
For example, here we've created a small
lambda function that checks whether the
title starts with the letter "L". Once we
apply this function with the filter method,
we get a subset of the data
consisting of just these titles.
So far we've been talking about the rows
of a dataset, but what about the columns?
The Datasets library has two main
methods for transforming columns:
a rename_column method to
change the name of a column,
and a remove_columns method to delete them.
You can see examples of both these method here.
Some datasets have nested columns and you can
expand these by applying the flatten method.
For example in the SQUAD dataset, the answers
column contains a text and answer_start field.
If we want to promote them to their own separate
columns, we can apply flatten as shown here.
Of course, no discussion of the Datasets
library would be complete without mentioning the
famous map method. This method applies a custom
processing function to each row in the dataset.
For example,here we first define a lowercase_title
function that simply lowercases the text in the
title column and then we feed that to the map
method and voila! we now have lowercase titles.
The map method can also be used to feed
batches of rows to the processing function.
This is especially useful for tokenization,
where the tokenizers are backed by the Tokenizers
library can use fast multithreading
to process batches in parallel.